now it is my turn to welcome you to
intelligence squared and to a debate
among four extremely distinguished
historians about one of the most
controversial moments in
twentieth-century history in September
of 1938 Prime Minister Neville
Chamberlain together with his French
counterpart agreed to let Adolf Hitler
occupy the Sudetenland an ethnically
German part of Czechoslovakia calling
the crisis a quarrel in a faraway
country between people of whom we know
nothing he returned home waving a
promise in that picture up there signed
by Hitler not to pursue war any further
so was he right to do so those in
support of this motion will argue yes
and those against will argue no at the
end of the evening you two get to see
heavier say and you will vote by tearing
your ballot ticket that's I was told to
show you this in case you didn't notice
that it was handed to you upon entry and
you tear it in two and you vote by
placing either the four or the against
part or there we go sorry for against
into the ballot box and if you are a
don't know which is almost inconceivable
after this distinguished panel speaks
you're bound to have very strong views
then you should place the entire ticket
in the ballot box so each of my speakers
is going to have twelve minutes maximum
to speak and at ten minutes I'm going to
ding my glass like this so be warned
this is very harsh very severe military
discipline which we have to impose on
with on these military historians in the
room our first speaker for the motion
for the motion is John Charlie professor
of modern history at the university of
east anglia who can now stand up and
he's the author of Chamberlain and the
lost piece as well as Churchill the end
of glory also as I recall he was the
author of a couple of controversial
articles in The Spectator some years
back which addressed precisely these
issues professor Charlie thank you very
much madam chairman
if I can start with a quotation and
finish with one it is also a help to our
country into a whole Empire on our whole
decent faithful way of living that it is
known through the world that we were
guiltless of the bloodshed terror and
misery which have engulfed so many
appeasement was a long term policy it
had been pursued by British governments
throughout the nineteenth twentieth
century one exception the Great War the
Great War did not suggest that getting
involved in a rock in Europe was really
very good idea so the first thing to say
about Neville is he simply pursuing a
policy that would be in the policy of
the British Empire with one disastrous
exception there was no body in the 1920s
and 30s arguing World War one have been
jolly good idea
in fact the policy of appeasement the
policy of amelioration and we should
come back to these things was reinforced
by the experience of getting involved in
world war war and that horrendous loss
of life so you could not have had a
public opinion less favorable to
fighting in foreign parts of course it
might have been open to the prime
minister to have done what a later prime
minister did perhaps sex up a dossier
really I would have thought of all
generations this generation would know
the foreign the utter foolishness of
trying to take a country to war that
does not want to go that would not have
conduced to one of the things that never
managed to conduce to which is a
national consensus that by the time war
came there was no alternative now if we
are in the presence of a long term
policy if we're in the presence of what
reinforced by the slaughter of
Passchendaele and the trenches we are
also in the presence of a
policy reinforced by economic reality in
1931 Britain had gone into what one used
to be able to say to me a serious
economic slump in its history but thanks
to Gordon & Company we have a much worse
one god it's probably being historic
even had to revise your comparisons
nonetheless the slump was serious the
great and good man up there had been the
Chancellor of the Exchequer who would
help nurse back a crippled economy the
Treasury warmed we could not afford is a
long war the War Office said we couldn't
win a short one oh how foolish of the
Prime Minister to listen to his advisers
now I think again we know from more
recent examples that is really rather a
good idea the Prime Minister's listened
to the men who paid to advise them and
perhaps to public opinion
and who knows Parliament and who knows
they might tell the truth all of these
things Neville did I will leave to my
learned friend professor Stan there are
many reasons why the other thing that
would have made war problematic was
Britain hadn't their allies I do hope he
mentions I commit Zog but I don't think
he would have deterred Hitler very much
but now to have reasoned itself it is
much misunderstood largely because of
church
appeasement was not simply a search for
peace what's wrong with peace I think
we're all rather in favor of it
particularly those of us with young sons
it was not a policy of peace at any
price as I shall say at the end but it
was a search to prove whether peace was
possible but it was also two other
things it was a search to see whether if
peace was not possible that would
produce a United Nation around a
different policy and it was accompanied
by a sensible rearm on policy not the
one favored by Churchill full of
medium-range bombers and make the
country as banker
as Churchill was Churchill was able to
win the Battle of Britain because
Neville Chamberlain's rearmament policy
produced the most sophisticated air
defense policy in Europe Spitfires and
radar and cue Neville
so it was not a piece at any price it
was not a disarmament policy it was a
search to see whether peace was possible
with an iron fist inside the velvet
glove and when in 1939 oh of course
with hindsight everybody as we shall no
doubt hear this evening has 20/20 vision
Hitler was a terrible man when nobody
doubts that so it was Stalin
so was Saddam Hussein so was Mussolini
in fact I'd never known a leader of
another country who was not demonized by
those seeking to go to war that's not
enough if we are ready to go to war on
the side of nice people with nice allies
we shall probably reduce to going to war
with the Isle of Man as our cell ally
and why not
so we have a situation where you have a
country that is still traumatized by the
great war still wishes to find a
peaceful way an establishment a
political establishment the degrees an
economic situation that won't allow for
it
a military situation was also going to
allow for it as professor stem will say
a foreign policy one that went either
it's not that appeasement was the right
policy it was the only conceivable
policy as Professor Paul Kennedy of Yale
has put it it was the most over
determined policy in British history
even if he was quoting professor Paul's
rather when he said it nor is it a
complete failure because when Britain
goes to war in 1939
there is the United country which that
would not have been if they've gone to
eat war a year earlier on a false
prospectus
Hitler has no allies because Mussolini
is mysteriously ill perhaps tying his
shoelaces and France goes with Britain
so Britain has an ally Hitler does not
of course in 1940 it all goes wrong
that's cuz the British and French army
were crap what was never supposed to do
imitate Stalin and shoot the general
staff I fear some of the general staff
at Hitler made of solid teak in the
bullet would have bounced off so
appeasement far from being a total
failure was an honorable attempt to see
whether or not peace was possible it
proved beyond peradventure and that's
why the country was united even in the
trauma of 1940 part from Oswald Mosley
and the buf needed locking up probably
need locking up earlier
nobody dissented what apart from a few
communists but if you've got Oswald
Mosley and the Communists against you
you're probably right
so to finish off it was not only the
right policy it was the only policy and
I want to finish with a quotation
whatever else history may or may not say
about these terrible tremendous years we
can be sure that Neville Chamberlain
acted with perfect sincerity according
to his lights and strove to the utmost
of his capacity and authority which were
powerful to avoid war to save the world
from this awful devastating struggling
which we are now engaged this alone will
stand him in good stead as far as what
is called the verdict of history well
tonight ladies and gentlemen you have
the chance to be that verdict and to
prove the author of those words what
Winston Churchill right
so remember when you come to cast your
vote vote Churchill proving right by
voting for Neville thank you very much
thank you so our first speaker against
the motion is Sir Richard Evans the
Regis professor of history and the
president of Wolfson College Cambridge
University and he's among his many books
his many books include the Third Reich
in power and the Third Reich at war huh
thank you very much madam madam chairman
ladies gentlemen I'm in in 1935 Hamid
Goering known as the second man in the
Third Reich arrived late at his hunting
lodge for a meeting with the British
ambassador Sir Eric Phipps I'd been out
hunting he said animals I hope said the
Ambassador and Fitz's reactions showed
how well he understood the murderous
nature of the Nazi regime I had the
impression he wrote in one dispatch that
the persons directing the policy of the
Hitler government are not normal many of
us indeed have a feeling that we're
living in a country where fanatics
hooligans and eccentrics have got the
upper hand already in 1935 Phipps wrote
let's hope our pacifists at home may at
length realize that the rapidly growing
monster of German militarism will not be
placated by mere cooing but will only be
restrained from recourse to its ultimate
Co ie war by the knowledge that the
powers who desire peace are also strong
enough to enforce it and when
Chamberlain came to power in 1937 as
Prime Minister immediately replaced
Phipps with some Neville Henderson who
thought Goering was a gentleman and told
the Foreign Office if we handle Hitler
right my belief is that he'll gradually
become more Pacific but if we treat him
as a pariah or mad dog we shall turn him
finally and irrevocably into one history
madam chairman ladies and gentlemen
history has shown that Phipps was right
and Henderson was wrong
Chamberlain knew little about Europe and
cared even less and as you've already
heard he told his listens to the BBC
radio broadcast in 1938 how
horrible fantastic incredible it is that
we should be digging trenches and trying
on gas masks here because of a quarrel
in a faraway country between people of
whom you know nothing the country was
speaking of wasn't Mongolia or
Antarctica it was text of our cure just
a few hundred miles away he was slow to
react to the German threat because he
didn't take it seriously and like
Henderson
unlike Phipps and the many well-informed
experts on continental Europe who
thought like Phipps Chamberlain regarded
Hitler at a normal conventional
statesman he as a man whose word can be
trusted he wrote in a letter to his
sister he had given him assurances that
he had no more territorial demands after
the Sudetenland the part of
Czechoslovakia that was taken away and
given to Germany in the Munich Agreement
to 1938 Hitler's were mrs. Bond waving
the scrap of paper hit at signed
Chamberlain told crowds that it meant
peace for our time and he should have
known that Goering had referred to all
treaties and scraps of paper to be torn
up when there were no use anymore
Munich appalled mi5 who according to the
official history were well-informed
enough to realize Hitler's aims were
without limit and that Poland would be
next
they sent Chamberlain a memo to try and
stiffen his resolve with secret
intelligence reports describing how
Hitler was absolutely contemptuous of
him in private describing him as a worm
and even an arch law which the mi5
translated accurately and hopefully as
[ __ ]
it had no effect Pisa was even more
dismayed to the German army chief of
staff Franz Halder who knew that Germany
in 1938 was in no way prepared for a war
with Britain and planned the arrest of
Hitler if war broke out to be followed
by immediate negotiations for peace how
the even went to his operational
conferences with Hitler carrying a
loaded revolver in his belt in case the
opportunity should arise for a quick
shot plans had reached an advanced stage
for a coup when the Munich Agreement
pulled the rug from underneath the
conspirators feet they were simply
stopped in their tracks by Chamberlain
who refused of course to believe that
the Germans weren't ready for war the
Czechs had a strong army they had
defensible borders the British backing
they could have resisted a German
invasion but Chamberlain forced them to
surrender British government refused to
believe that Germany wasn't ready for
war even in 1936 when German rearmament
had made so little progress that when
Hitler sending his troops to the
Rhineland
in the west of Germany which is a
demilitarized zone by the terms of the
peace settlement in 1919 the troops are
under orders to withdraw the slightest
sign of anglo-french objection had the
French sent in troops for example in
tercera later
the military force at our disposal would
not have been enough even for the
limited resistance strong action by the
British in 1936 or 38 could have
prevented war with all its disastrous
loss of British lives it would have
encouraged resistance to Hitler within
Germany as it was both the unopposed
remilitarization of the Rhineland and
the Munich Agreement over Czechoslovakia
persuaded Hitler they did nothing to
fear from the feeble witless British and
their supine allies the French far from
calming him down these events along with
the unopposed annexation of Austria in
March 1938 all fruits the policy of
appeasement made him accelerate his
policy of conquest and aggression now
what you think of appeasement depends of
course on what you think Hitler's aims
were Chamberlain and I'm in full
agreement here with presently a decent
and sincere man thought Hitler just
wanted a few revisions of the Treaty of
Versailles in the name of the
self-determination of the German people
but knowledgeable and intelligent man
like Phipps knew from the very beginning
this wasn't the case and anyone who read
my camp faithless political tract from
the mid 20s or who listened carefully to
his speeches or who found out what he'd
been saying to his generals or even to
American business magnate correspondents
knew he was planning a war of European
conquest and ultimately aiming at world
domination war was the essence of the
Nazi regime men like fits store this
from the start
Chamberlain horizons were too limited to
conventional to grasp this basic reality
there's no evidence that he had some
kind of cunning plan to keep Hitler on
hold while Britain rearmed he was in
fact naively obsessed with a desire to
avoid war at any price on the 2nd of
November 1939 following the Nazi
invasion of Poland he appeared for the
House of Commons placing his faith in
Italian mediation extraordinarily in the
Cellini of all people the most
unreliable people in modern history the
members of the House Commons who knew
full well that the Nazis were aiming for
European domination that Poland was just
the first step were furious so leader of
the opposition rose to his feet began
with the words speaking for the Labour
Party a Tory back Venturer shouted
angrily speak for England a few hours
later an emergency meeting of the
cabinet forced Chamberlain to issue an
ultimatum to the Germans to withdraw
when this is ignored a declaration of
war issued over the radio by visibly
shattered and disappointed Prime
Minister now let me remind you this
point so draw my remarks to close the
motion is not whether Chamberlain was
pretty pursuing a tried and tested
British policy it's not whether this is
the only policy available to the rigid
government it's not whether the Treasury
didn't allow him any choice it's not
whether public opinion wasn't behind it
the motion is about whether the policy
of appeasement Chamberlain's policy of
appeasement was in the best interests of
Britain it was not a search to prove
whether peace was possible as I've
argued it was a it was a desperate
search for peace at any price pleaselet
was not in Britain's national interest
because it prevented Britain and France
and putting a stop to Hitler's drive for
world domination when it was still
possible to do so indeed because it
actually encouraged it was not in
Britain's national interest because it
undermined opposition to Hitler from the
leadership of the German armed forces it
was not in Britain's national interest
because if Britain left left Britain
woefully unprepared for war when it came
as the disasters of the first year of
the war showed till things began to
improve a bit
with the Battle of Britain it wasn't in
Britain's national interest because
leaving continental Europe to its own
devices would have been a betrayal of
staggering proportions first for
Czechoslovakia then for Poland and for
the rest of Europe 4ps Minh had
continued as Chamberlain wanted it to
even during a Nazi invasion of Poland
Hitler would have scored an even more
complete victory in Europe than he did
in 1940 Britain and the Empire would
have been next in line thank you very
much
thank you very much trust a the Regis
professor of history to get it correct
it was peace for our time and not peace
in our time right our second speaker for
the motion is Glyn Stone the professor
of international history at the
university of the west of england and
the author of books on a huge range of
subjects from Neville Chamberlain and
the Spanish Civil War to anglo-french
relations in the 1930s Flinstone you've
heard my colleague John Charlie argue
that appeasement was the best policy for
the British government
and I have no reason whatsoever to
disagree with that verdict I think he
has demonstrated very much that it
wasn't only the best policy it was the
only policy and in considering this
question we ought to also bear in mind
that there ought to be alternatives to
this if it wasn't appeasement then what
was the best alternative what was a
better policy than that of appeasement
and historians tend to come up with just
as Churchill came up with and so on with
the idea of a grand alliance a grand
alliance of the powers because after all
that was what is defeated the Kaiser in
the First World War and that was what of
course he eventually defeated that of
Hitler in the Second World War so it
made sense common sense therefore for
Chamberlain and his government to
construct a grand alliance to deter and
to confront Hitler with with with war
now of course the question is is this
realistic I'd certainly Chamberlain
didn't believe it to be realistic it was
an occasion in march 1938 when he in a
letter to one of his sisters he wrote
regular correspondence with both of his
sisters he mentioned to her that the
whole question had been examined the
idea of a grand alliance had been under
great scrutiny and the Chiefs of Staff
had been involved and so on and it was a
marvelous idea in theory but the problem
was in practice that when it came down
to practicalities the whole thing
disintegrated and it was quite right
there was no way no possible way of
constructing a grand
Alliance in the 1930s that might deter
an oppose Hitler the only realistic
combination in the 1930s of powers was
that which actually materialized that of
an anglo-french alliance and that of
course materialized in march in
february/march in 1939
neither the Soviet Union nor the United
States was prepared to commit to an
alliance to confront and deter Hitler's
Germany
neither neither of those parts whether
Franklin Roosevelt or Joseph Stalin if
we look at the Americans
first of all we see America deep in
isolation
ever since the fateful decision of 1919
when the Senate rejected the Treaty of
Versailles and America's membership of
the League of Nations America to
increasingly become deeply and much more
isolated as far as International Affairs
was concerned and the height of American
isolationism was reached of course in
the mid 1930s with the neutrality
legislation passed through Congress and
that of course coincides with the period
of Neville Chamberlain's government
Franklin Delano Roosevelt was reluctant
to get involved in any of the affairs in
Europe or in the Far East whether it be
Abyssinia whether it be the Spanish
Civil War whether it be the
sino-japanese war which broke out in the
summer of 1937 Chamberlain was
absolutely correct when he said on one
occasion you can expect nothing from the
Americans only words certainly not
actions that would be the last thing an
America would offer and the Czech crisis
of course I think demonstrates this
probably better than anything else
because during that crisis a time and
again American diplomats were
discouraging both the British and the
French from taking action that might
lead to war they for example a bullet in
Paris as William Bullock the ambassador
in Paris constantly telling French
politicians and statesmen that they
could expect no help from the United
States and indeed at the height of the
Czech crisis when it looked like war was
going to occur as the
British Navy mobilizing as the French
garnered their Armed Forces and
Roosevelt I made an appeal to both
Chamberlain but also to a doll fitler as
well and followed up with another
personal appeal to Hitler appealing for
peace and to find some way a solution so
that there would not necessarily be war
over the Czech issue and when
Chamberlain announced that he was going
to a Munich on the 28th of September
1938 Roosevelt sent him a telegram a
telegram was two words good man good man
and so when Chamberlain delivered the
verdict to Munich Roosevelt afterwards
mentioned to several of his confidence
that he was not at all disappointed
about the outcome of the Czech crisis
itself and there is no doubt that
Roosevelt was incapable really of
persuading is Congress to adopt a more
supportive policy with regard to Britain
and to France this is clearly shown when
in 1939 during the spring and summer of
1939 the French were making a bid for
French American aircraft trying to buy
weapons from the United States to help
with their rearmament Congress refused
even though Roosevelt himself was in
favor of this Congress refused to
endorse what we call a policy of cash
and carry to enable the French and the
British to buy weapons and other
materials and pay for them with with
cash that policy was only adopted in
November 1939 after the war had started
if we look at the Soviet Union we can
see that again that the charges be made
against Chamberlain that he failed to
secure an alliance with the Soviets and
that he was to blame for this because of
his blind ideological prejudices against
the Soviet Union well there's no doubt
that Chamberlain and his cabinet were
all anti-communist but at the same time
they were also of course aware
of the Soviets they were aware of the
military problems that the Soviets were
experiencing largely because of the
destruction of the Soviet High Command
the purges in the Red Army in 1937 98 38
but a huge question mark over the
military credibility of the Soviet armed
forces but apart from that there was
also a question of trust could you trust
of Stalin would Stalin actually make an
agreement and alliance with Britain and
France well at one level it looked like
that might be possible because
negotiations took place in the spring
and summer of 1939 to make an alliance
but in the end of course as we all know
Stalin opted for an agreement with Nazi
Germany in the infamous nazi-soviet
non-aggression pact of the 23rd of
August 1939 and the reason he did that
was because he was able to gain massive
benefits and advantages from that
association benefits and advantages
which he could not possibly have got
from Britain and France Britain and
France could not sell Poland down the
river could not sell the Baltic States
down the river could not sell theirs
Arabia down the river the same time they
could not offer the sort of economic
support which Stalin himself believed he
needed and Stalin was able of course to
pay for that back by providing raw
materials and foodstuffs to the 3rd Rush
and also of course by making the pact
Stalin bought himself time time to
reconstruct the Soviet economy and time
also to undo the damage that had been
done to the Soviet armed forces through
the purges time and absolutely valuable
commodity and by making that alliance
that was very much favorable favorable
decision for Stalin to make but above
all with regard to this there was also
an opportunity with regard to the pact
that in actual fact Britain and France
might go to war with Germany and that
therefore there would be a war of the
capitalist powers fighting each other
and if they fought each other in a
similar way as they'd fought during the
First World War this will be a long war
of attrition and the effect would be the
there would be a I said a long drawn-out
struggle that the various parties would
exhaust themselves and this would leave
Stalin as Russia meanwhile rearming for
all it's worth in a much much stronger
position to dictate the future of Europe
and there is no doubt that this was in
Stalin's mind because four days before
he made a pact he said as much to a
meeting of the Politburo on the 19th of
August on the 23rd of August president
Benesch former president of
Czechoslovakia now in exile in London
spoke with the IVA my ski the ambassador
of the Soviet Union and again got a same
message from from my sake
and then on the 7th of September a week
after the war had broken out in a
meeting with Zidane off who was a member
of Politburo with Molotov the foreign
minister and with GOG dimitrov the head
of the Comintern or third international
Stalin again repeated the advantages and
opportunities which would be available
for the Soviets should this war continue
for a long time as he himself hoped it
would so there was no prospect at all of
making any alliance in 1930s and
especially in 1939 with the Soviet Union
and the fact is of course that Stalin
would strive might and main after
September 1939 to maintain soviet-german
collaboration up to the point of even
dismissing intelligence reports in 1941
about an impending and invasion
about that Nazi Germany which of course
took place on June 22nd 1941 this
finally therefore leaves us with the one
Alliance which Britain had that with
France
the problem with France was was France a
credible ally France was riven by social
and political problems and as a
consequence of these problems
it put a question mark over the the
credibility of the French particularly
in terms of their rearmament simply the
the the power of their of their military
forces and the bottom line was at the
end that despite this Chamberlain made
an alliance with the French
and the two countries went together
together in September 1939 to fight
against Adolf Hitler they're the only
two countries actually who declared war
upon Hitler's Germany
certainly Joseph Stalin and Franklin
Roosevelt didn't thank
right our final speaker against the
motion is Piers Brendan the former
keeper of the Churchill archive centre
and fellow of Churchill College
Cambridge and among other things the
author of the dark valley a panorama of
the 1930s
Winston Churchill memorably defined Anna
Pisa as one who feeds a crocodile hoping
it will eat him last like me of
Churchill's impromptu remarks this one
was carefully prepared in advance but it
did not express his full mind on the
subject appeasement as he admitted need
not be a matter of Cardus it could mean
peaceful conciliation Churchill also
acknowledged that Neville Chamberlain
and John
Charlie had said had good motives for
trying to appease the dictators during
the 1930s he wanted to avoid a repeat of
the first world war he wanted to right
the wrongs of the Versailles settlement
and to preserve the empire without
jeopardizing the British economy during
the Depression however as I shall try to
persuade you the appeasement policy as
actually implemented by Chamberlain
which sacrificed the Czechs to Hitler in
December 1938 was an absolute disaster
when Chamberlain returned from Munich in
triumph clutching his umbrella waving
his piece of paper and announcing that
he'd brought peace with honor
Churchill was right to respond that
Britain had been offered a choice
between war and shame she has chosen
shame and she will get war of course
Churchill himself has neither
consistent nor infallible but he did
grasp the full danger of Nazism as early
as March 1934 Churchill alerted
Parliament to the tumultuous insurgent
insurgents of ferocity and war spirit in
Germany Chamberlain would not listen
arguing with Churchill he said was like
arguing with a brass band he wasn't far
wrong in that particular point but
Churchill had a better point when he
said that Chamberlain a good Lord Mayor
of Birmingham in a lean year looked at
Foreign Affairs looked at Foreign
Affairs through the wrong end of a
municipal drainpipe Churchill could
could couldn't see that Hitler wanted
war he could he thought he could do a
deal he offered him various titbits such
as the return of Germany's former
colonies not realizing how unimportant
these were to Hitler and ignoring
Bismarck's warning that he who seeks to
buy the friendship of his enemy with
concessions will never be rich enough
it was insatiable lust for conquest his
pathological anti-semitism his insensate
drive to win Lebensraum in the east his
homicidal quest for an Aryan World Order
all this was beyond the comprehension of
Chamberlain it was a smart vain
fundamentally naive man who thought that
jokes in Christmas crackers were funny
and liked to win at games and musical
chairs and only really showed anger when
his umbrella got broken the national
government's first great act of
appeasement took place in response to
Mussolini's rape of Ethiopia in 1935 the
Royal Navy could have crushed this in a
moment just by blockading the Suez Canal
and the and this would have had a great
moral effect throughout Europe and
unshunned and helped to shut hit the
ramp or at least to warn him that that
we meant business as the military
historian little Hart wrote never again
would the be so good a chance to check
an aggressor so early and the failure to
do so in this case was the most fateful
turning point in the history in the
period between the wars the national
government heeding the supposedly but
not really a pacifist electorate was
timorous over the react in its reaction
to nazi rearmament which violated the
Treaty of Versailles and to Hitler's
reoccupation of the Rhineland in 1936
which violated the Treaty of Locarno
equally feeble was their response to
Hitler Caesar of Austria in March 1938
Lord Halifax
kind of Christian said Churchill who
deserved to be thrown to the Lions sent
a pathetic protest which Hitler
contemptuously ignored meanwhile a
pogrom was taking place in Vienna whose
ferocity embarrassed even the Gestapo
itself some of Austria's 400,000 Jews
fled to Berlin where the anti-semitism
was less acute despite such evidence of
Nazi barbarity and belligerents
Chamberlain neglected potential allies
he cold shouldered Roosevelt ostracized
Stalin snubbed alladhi a once remarking
that the French but for the French
premier the darkest R was always before
lunch but but Chamberlain ardently wooed
ma Cellini
whereas Churchill agreed with Goering
practically anything they did agree
about which was that in any future war
it would be a positive advantage to have
Italy as an enemy in his eagerness to
modify Hitler however Chamberlain
confirmed Mussolini's view that the
decadent Britain was led by political
eunuchs he said that the Ethiopians had
obviously caught them young Ethiopians
went in for castration the impression of
impotence was compounded by
Chamberlain's appointment of obtuse
mediocrities such as Sir Thomas inskipp
the Minister for the Coordination to
defense of whom it was said that he
could look with Frank and fearless gaze
on any prospect
however appalling and failed to see it
similarly Chamberlain's real menthe
programme was too cautious and
penny-pinching to convince the dictators
that he would stand up to them at no
risk to the economy he could have done
far more to provide the seniors of war
British soldiers understandably feared
that the government's real aim was as
one said not to fight a war but to be
able to pay an indemnity after losing it
combined with half-hearted rearmament
wholehearted appeasement invited the
aggression that it was designed to
prevent
no wonder the French called Chamberlain
Monsieur a shame bear Helene Hitler was
convinced that the democracies would
cave in when he Menace Czechoslovakia in
the summer of 1938 and he was undeterred
by diplomatic hints that Britain would
intervene if he used force
not least because the foreign office
simultaneously pressed president Bennish
of czechoslovakia to yield by hinting
that britain would not intervene some
officials did urge firmness and even the
head of the Foreign Office so Alexander
Cadogan was shocked when Chamberlain
argued quite calmly for total surrender
after Chamberlain's three airborne
overtures to Hitler which culminated in
the session session of the SU date
infringe of the cheques of a key of the
german-speaking fringe at the Munich
conference this saying echoed around
Whitehall if at first you can't concede
fly fly fly again however humiliating
the terms though Chamberlain's defenders
argue that Munich gave Britain a vital
vital breeding spray breathing space in
which to defend itself notably with
fighters and radar yet as John Charlie
himself acknowledges this was not his
intention Chamberlain's main objective
says John was to avert war and he was
prepared to go a very long way down the
road of national dishonor to get his way
as it was Germany made much better use
of the years grace than Britain and
France the democracies would have done
well to fight in 1938 when the Luftwaffe
had no plans or ability to bomb London
the French had a 5 to 1 superiority to
Germany on the on its vulnerable western
border and 35 well-equipped Czech
divisions perhaps supported by the Red
Army would have embroiled Hitler in a
war on two fronts after Munich no
full-blooded rearmament program was
initiated in Britain largely because
Chamberlain assumed that he'd secured
peace the British public was less
gullible after the initial euphoria
about Munich it quickly concluded with
hawks like Churchill that Munich had
been a total and unmitigated defeat and
that the Nazis were criminals whose
hands are still dripping with blood and
who have just slapped our embarrassed
faces before the whole world the abject
failure of appeasement was confirmed in
March 1939 when Hitler swallowed the
whole of Czechoslovakia Chamberlain's
reluctant response was to guarantee the
independence of Hitler's next major
target Poland among other countries
yet this did not mark the end of
appeasement it was a further attempt to
contain and deter Germany not a
preparation for war but a construction
of a peace front anyway the times which
was pieces softened its commitment to
Poland and sir Neville Henderson are
pro-nazi ambassador in Berlin sabotage
dick to the fury fury of Clifford Norton
the British chargee d'affaires all and
he wrote in an unpublished memo to the
Foreign Office this very interesting
memo the historian of the future may
well ask what right Henderson had to
falsify the British spirit and attempt
to drag our name in the mud again God
knows if Poland fights it will be hell
for her and for all of us but there is a
worse hell for cards and traitors then
for those who go down because they kept
their word
Hitler was encouraged by other signs of
appeasement among among them dove like
wings from the BBC Britain Sark Tisha's
payment of Dane geld in the shape of
foreign credits to Germany the continued
exclusion of Churchill from the cabinet
and Chamberlain's ineffectual courting
of starting having seen the Democratic
worms at Munich Hitler Hitler said he
could not believe that they would now
turn succumbing to his own illusions he
was convinced that the democracies would
lead the poles in the lurch
Chamberlain's own illusions flourished
Hitler has concluded that we mean
business he said on the 23rd of July
1939 and that this time and that the
time is not ripe for a major war that's
sir six weeks I suppose before the war
was declared after the nazi-soviet pact
even after the assault on Poland began
he clung to the hope that Hitler might
be peace of peacefully placated as a
threat to Britain's existence and a
menace to Western civilization if not as
the embodiment of evil Hitler should
have been confronted earlier
Chamberlain's tragically mistaken policy
made his Premiership the darkest hour
before our finest hour I beg to oppose
the motion
I can now announce the these are the
results of the voting that you did
before you heard the four panelists
speak so before the debate there were
25% for the motion 41% against the
motion and 34% don't know so I reckon
that that 34% is is the the four motion
can still win if it wins over this 34%
don't know I will take questions in
groups of three
please make you can make short
statements you can ask a question to one
or two all of the panelists please and I
will do my best to see with lights
blaring in my eyes right gentlemen right
here in blue well a key point which has
only been mentioned by one of two other
speakers is of course is the fact that
dirty of course gave full support to
Neville chained me throughout as I
understand it when as I my
understandings that when the the whole
thing started got going in April 1938
Bono the farmer Esther went to London
and basically conceded you know said
whatever you whatever you decide will
support and of course that last one is
it is that Wendell area returned from
Munich he thought he was going to be
lynched but in fact erm he faced
cheering crowds all the way for know
from the airport into Paris and the
French National Assembly overwhelmingly
approved the Munich Agreement with just
the Communists voting against and this
is a very important thing which should
we borne in mind right in in orange in
the back oh hi um I wanted to ask about
um getting Guernica pronounce that
correctly um
because for the first time a Guernica
showed us that the war could come to the
civilian population and not be fought in
a far-off land and I understood that we
believed it was possible we could lose
up to 60,000 civilians in about a week
to two weeks from bombing and that
Guernica had taught is quite a lesson
that Neville Chamberlain was quite aware
of and we were not prepared
at that point - you know evacuate people
we didn't know about that or we couldn't
have done this at that point it's not
not correct right thank you and one more
and then what happens would evening and
Pierce Brendon talks of Neville
Chamberlain ostracizing Stalin
well if talking to Stalin is such a good
idea what's so wrong with talking to
Hitler alright okay so maybe we'll start
there was one direct question for Piers
Brendan maybe he would like to answer
that and then we'll sorry I'm de la da
I'd like to answer that and then you get
de la dia next so yes I'd like to answer
answer all of them but that would be
cheating yes of course it's the
difference between a lovely isn't it
Stalin and and and Hitler the difference
I suppose is this that Hitler pose an
existential threat to this country
whereas Stalin had his own problems in
in the late 1930s and in the end of
course it is absolutely true that
Chamberlain did try to mend his fences
with Stalin but he did it in an
extraordinarily inept way he sent a
cross as his emissary not a senior
politician to negotiate with Stalin
because he wanted to come to some sort
of grand alliance with Stalin at this
late stage he sent an emissary called
Admiral original Plunkett only old Drax
and Surrey gional Plunkett only old Drax
when he arrived in Moscow was greeted
with incredulity by the Russians partly
because of his name and partly because
he didn't seem to carry any weight and
and and and finally because it turned
out that he didn't have any authority to
act for the British government this was
the kind of ineptitude that that that
that Chamberlain was guilty of in other
words he did not make a serious effort
to create anything in the way of a grand
alliance and
Churchill who who's anti-communist
record was was greater than anybody's
that you could think of came to that
awkward and embarrassed conclusion by
about 1938 that the real menace was
posed by Hitler and that he would
therefore have to swallow his
anti-communist I mean he had written
these wonderful things about how that
the the Bolsheviks like hordes of
ferocious baboons were hopping and
capering over the ruins of civilization
and all that sort of thing but he came
around in 1938 but realistically to
saying what we need is the kind of
alliance that we had in 1914 with the
Russians right professor stone can I
just come back on that for answer your
de la da one because we hear again and
again about Neville Chamberlain and the
negotiations with the Soviet Union and
that they didn't show any real
seriousness or sincerity about it and
that the military mission headed by Drax
is a clear proof of that the fact of the
matter is wouldn't matter if we sent all
our top generals we'd sent cabinet
ministers or anyone else Stalin was not
not going to make an alliance with
Britain in the summer of 1939 because he
had a much much better offer and that
offer came from Adolphe Hitler and the
offer contained as I was saying in my
speech that things that Britain and
France could not possibly give as
democratic countries they were not able
to do what Stalin was able to do cut a
bargain with sorry Hitler cut a bargain
with Stalin so it's immaterial whether
Drax went where there was a slow boat to
Moscow which has also been pointed out
in issues of that kind that fundamental
and crucial issue was about whether or
not the Soviet Union would support this
country and France in a war against Nazi
Germany and Stalin had no intention of
getting involved in that kind they were
all capitalist powers as far as he was
concerned and as far as he was concerned
the best outcome would be a war between
the three from which the Soviet Union
itself would benefit de la da you're
quite right in September 1938 the French
are absolutely hysterical about this
coming war and don't forget it's their
problem
more than Britain's they've the ones
who've got the Treaty of agreement with
the Czechs not the British we are no way
obliged or committed to support
Czechoslovakia in 1938 absolutely not
and to be committed and to actually go
to war on behalf of France because
that's what we will be doing we would
have to be absolutely convinced that we
were putting our entire nation at risk
and I mean at real in genuine risk on
behalf of an issue of three million
Germans rejoining the Third Reich
because that's what this a date an issue
is about and if that could be actually
brought about you could resolve that
issue then peacefully then that was
worth worth worth worth very much and if
you could also get if this agreement to
conduct a diplomatic relations in a more
peaceful manner in future as propel the
Anglo German declaration that would be
as well but can I just say when
Chamberlain was coming back from the
airport in England
and he made that silly statement about
peace in our time and so on he actually
turned to Lord Halifax and he said
Edward we must hope for the best we must
prepare for the worst and therefore it
made absolute sense to pursue a policy
that would ensure that you will continue
to try and strive to reach an agreement
but that you are not going to do new the
defenses of your own country you're
going to prepare it to make it ready for
war subsequently if that proved
impossible but for Daladier can just say
one point the French absolutely
hysterical because they had no way of
defending their country by air the
French Air Force was a way behind that
of both the Royal Air Force and other
fafa voluma the French editor chief of
the air staff told the de la DEA that
the air force would last up best six
weeks so they have a reason to support a
Chamberlain at Munich professor Evans
you you were interested in answering the
question war could have hurt civilians
we weren't prepared for that yes
there's a reference there was a question
about gennyca
which is a Basque town which was bombed
to bits in the Spanish Civil War by a
German bombers of the so-called Condor
Legion
and with serious loss of life and it was
this led to kind of widespread
fear across Europe of bombing it was
thought that the next war would be an
air war and there was no really
satisfactory effective defense against
aerial bombardment now
Chamberlain typically of course was
extremely ill informed about the the
German what he regarded as the German
military threat the Germans didn't
actually have a very effective strategic
bombing force certainly not in 1936
seven or eight and with severe
limitations even even in the Battle of
Britain he enormous ly overestimated the
the German potentiality but that the
real effect of Galica was in Germany
itself where people were absolutely
terrified of the next war Hitler did not
have a support amongst the ordinary
German people for a war the secret
reports of the SS surveillance service
roots of good talking and I've listened
to people and cues and on trams and so
on and made it quite clear then every
crisis 1936 remilitarization the
Rhineland and 38 Austria 30 30 and in
Czechoslovakia people were suffered from
what they called a war psychosis they
were absolutely frightened that there
would be war in beginning of September
1939 the Comerica correspondent William
Shara went out when war was declared
looking for the cheering crowds that
have been there in August 1914 nobody
streets absolutely empty everybody very
depressed about a war with some
justification because the Germans
weren't prepared either professor
Charlie that Chamberlain overestimated
the German potential and the Germans
were not prepared or enthusiastic for
war true-false nor were the British the
difference is Hitler could afford to
ignore his public opinion because he
wasn't going to be elected to anything
Chamberlain had the sob beliefs as a
democratic prime minister he should
actually listen to what public about
view and clearly not one that modern
neoconservatives or indeed
those who seem to think that some weird
sort of ethical foreign policy would
have worked in the 1930s would share
well that's fine fact of the matter is
that the policy advocated by the other
side simply was not crack is no point
with 20/20 hindsight saying we know this
we didn't know it then and everybody is
a winner I mean you know if you ask me
what last week's lottery numbers where I
could win it for you
the other side are very much knowing
what last week's lottery numbers was
after the event professor Evans wants
one sentence history history is all
about hindsight without hindsight we
wouldn't be historians right hindsight
right three more questions I see a
married couple quarreling who gets to
ask the question okay the wife is
conceding husband first and then sorry
and then in the white shirt there and
then one more up there is it not true
that both the Canadians and the
Australians had made it quite clear that
if we had gone in 1938 they would not
have been with us and that being the
case is it really conceivable that
without the support of the Commonwealth
we would have had the British people
truly onside in time to get the effort
going so question about what Canadians
and Australians would not have gone with
us in 1938 yep um next basically my
question would be that if we had
attacked Germany and we do declared war
and we were going to attack Germany at
that point wouldn't that have actually
driven the German people to support
Hitler in the defense of Germany and
then your into a full-blown war and then
even if you win that you're back in the
space of where we are with Iraq today
for instance hmm right see you some
applause here for the question and there
was one up here
no resigned okay to somebody else front
row there right
no wait gotta wait for the microphone
what was timberlands
calculation with regard to Poland when
he offer guarantees did he simply mean
to prolong the transition they did to
have longer period of preparation for
law or did he mean it seriously right
was Chamberlain serious about Poland so
professor Charlie is it correct that the
Canadians and Australians would not have
supported war in 1938 and wouldn't it
wouldn't that have riled up the Germans
as well and what yes yes jolly good
points if you go round declaring wars on
war on people they didn't say oh that's
a joke they fight back and oddly enough
you should declare war on and their
people rally round the regime on the
Empire point absolutely rise people
sometimes say the Britain stood alone in
1940's another one of those Churchill in
exaggerations they actually stand with
the United Empire around the menagerie
if you look at what the Canadians in
particular contribute to the British war
effort in 1940 it's tremendous they
would not have been there in 1938 nor
would South Africa nor indeed with the
rest of the Empire and this problem
people forget that Britain was not a
little half shore island back there
worldwide Empire
oh let's ignore the Empire let let again
it's very well to say course we're all
these stories with hindsight what one
shouldn't do is to ignore the
circumstances of the times Lord Macaulay
a very great a weak historian once said
the real task of the historian is to
remember what is now past was once the
future and people know as much about it
as we know about our future and I think
that's a very good point to me right
professor Evans just
well let me just remind you again of the
motion which is the best policy for the
British government in our judgement
knowing what happened later um that is
that is that is all about that is all
about history is all about results and
outcomes and we we are in a very
privileged situation we know what
happened and from that point of view we
can judge whether Chamberlain the
British government were right or not in
their policy as for the question about
Germany 9:38 just just to remind you
that as I said general Haldor and a
whole bunch of leading generals are
ready to stage a coup d'etat if a war
broke out so those who were the only
group who were in power and who had it
who had enough power clout who were able
to stage a conspiracy of that sort would
I think of acted without if there had
been a war Germany was weak in 1938 they
knew it it didn't require the entire
British Empire to to fight against the
Germans just one portion of collapse
from inside groaning groaning you
instead of groaning speak yes I'm
drowning almost because how can a
Democratic leader base a policy on what
might happen if you take or don't take
particular action with regard to
opposition's within another country
whether the army would or would not have
acted in that way how can you take a
risk that might then lead to a war which
will involve the lives of millions and
millions of people and that was the
thought at the time that the war would
bring huge civilian casualties as well
as battlefield casualties but it's
interesting to note in September 1939 8
that first of all you have the
Sudetenland
well the Sudetenland is where the
fortifications are and the problem is is
lots of Germans in the Sudetenland and
what are they going to do which were
they going to go in terms can the Czechs
rely upon the will upon the loyalty of
their German population and also it's
clear Peter Jackson historian of French
intelligence wrote an article a number
of years ago in which he pointed out
that French intelligence was absolutely
convinced that the Czechs would be
rolled over in
to a matter of days so this argument
about whether or not the there were
formidable fortifications formidable
Czech forces etc is one of course as all
things are debatable and from the French
point of view at the time there was a
clear feeling that Czechoslovakia would
not be able to withstand assault by the
by the German forces and bearing in mind
of course as well that what the French
would have done was mobilized behind the
Maginot Line right they had no real
offensive capability to actually attack
Germany
I see desire for response on this side
of course
the Czech army was extremely well
equipped it was very modern up-to-date
unlike the poles
it had defensible lines the Germans were
certainly pretty convinced that there
would be a really hard fight if they
tried to invade it what they did not
think there will be a roll over the the
the question was that again I think Dean
the Germans were in a position in 1938
where they felt weak they felt
vulnerable that was a moment for Britain
and France to put their foot down and
say it's not going any further even more
so in 1936 when Germany barely started
to rearm right three more questions Oh
No are you ok I just there as well we
haven't yet
yes about a very quick one which is I I
think that we haven't sort of examined
that the nature of of Chamberlain's
prime ministership it one MP said that
he was that the Fuhrer of the of the
Conservative Party in other words he was
he was not a weak Prime Minister he was
a strong Prime Minister and um what one
of the things that he did very very
consistently as my book still available
in all good book waterstones to Lisbon
after this ladies and gentlemen
shows is that the propaganda incentive
was terrific
during the
during the the late 30s I mean the times
was on side the BBC was I mean so so
involved that even children's are could
not broadcast programs about current
affairs the recksleeper who was in
charge of the Foreign Office's
propaganda department said that he could
turn around British opinion in in three
weeks simply by using the propaganda
weapons at his disposal and where the
Commonwealth was concerned they tended
to go to follow the line that the that
10 Downing Street was was pursuing and
therefore I I don't at all think that
it's a foregone conclusion that the
Commonwealth would not have come round
had there been a leadership that was
actually defending Britain's national
interests in 1938 as opposed to
sacrificing right three more questions
and of course the speaker's can return
to some of those that were unanswered in
this round because I know but catch it
in the later round okay so okay my
question is though with the opening
remarks the appeasement has been used
over almost a century of foreign policy
previous to world war ii and the fact
that Britain was unprepared up until
declaring war I'm would you therefore
advocate that going to what over Poland
was actually the wrong thing and that in
fact Britain should have let Hitler take
Poland to not get involved in war in
which case either
the freedom of the D half of Europe and
acceptable casualty to allow us to live
comfortably at home in the United
Kingdom right so another question about
Poland was it an acceptable casualty
next next
and professor Charlie attempt to put
Chamberlain's policy in to fit it into
the pattern of British foreign policy
during the 19th century I would put it
that that's wrong British policy in the
19th century was indeed built on non
involvement with Europe but it was also
strong defense of British interests and
credible deterrence which did on one or
two occasions lead to war I would say
canning castle or a Melbourne Disraeli
and of course Palmerston none of them
would have behaved as supine Lee as
Chamberlain and let's potential
opponents take vital vital victories at
Britain's and its allies expense number
three no one's mentioned the resignation
of Antony Eden he resigned before Munich
on the basis that he and Chamberlain had
fallen out because Roosevelt had
suggested to Chamberlain that Roosevelt
would share a Peace Conference in 1938
I'm curious to know why no one none of
the speakers have mentioned this point
because Eden had a clear vision of an
alternative we've been offered two or
turns as either war or peace Eden had a
different program and he resigned it
because Chamberlain wouldn't agree with
him
I'd like some comments on that if
possible right thank you three good
questions we'll start with number one
was that this one was directed directly
at professor Charlie was British policy
in the 19th century in fact based on a
long involvement with Europe and did
Chamberlain therefore was he there for a
long out of step with what had come
before if I can try and deal with both
and the deterrence issue because they
are actually part of the same thing I
think that the evidence is that where as
for example with Portugal Spain British
see how it could be used then certainly
Britain was able effectively to
intervene
however when it was a matter of Central
Europe say for example the
austro-prussian war even the
franco-prussian war and one only has to
mention although one doesn't want to get
into it but we are in the Royal
Geographical Society the Sheikh hold on
crisis and the plain fact automatic
right so the plain fact of the matter is
that certainly where Britain's
deterrence could be used that's the Navy
Britain intervened where she could not
she did not and last time I looked
Poland wasn't really amenable to British
sea power and Czech Slovakia was
landlocked so I think that in that sense
Chamberlain's policy was exactly one
without of the 15th Earl of Derby with
that of the 14th Earl of Aberdeen where
it involved an area that Britain could
not fight they actually agreed with
camming which is eat is better not to
bluff where you cannot be effective but
of course if any we'd known all the
German secrets and we hadn't listened to
our intelligence well if my auntie was
my uncle she'd have a different set of
equipment
right we have a taker for the Antony
Eden question role of Anthony Eden
significance there of peers Brendon
Antony is an interesting figure um he
was the son of a half mad baronet in a
very beautiful woman and somebody said
that he was a little bit of both himself
and the problem with Eden was that he
that he was highly emotional and he fell
out with she fell out with Chamberlain
really I think because he felt miffed
that Chamberlain had taken a front seat
in in foreign policy
I think Eden was pretty overrated
he was as Beaverbrook described him he
was a rebel in velvet gloves and he he
was not not really he was regarded by
Churchill as a sort of white hope of the
future and I I don't think that I think
the proof of the pudding was in 1956
where he proved that he wasn't the white
hope at all that he was an absolute
disaster area
III think he didn't represent any
serious resistance to the appeasement
policy if you look at what he said he
was very feeble and after he'd resigned
he didn't really support Churchill in
his his assault on upon appeasement so I
I would say really that Eden is a bit of
a broken Reed in this particular area
and I'd certainly always have preferred
Churchill drunk to Eden so right we've
now had two could do one word about Eden
and then we're gonna move to public
cause you did raise the question about
Roosevelt and about the Roosevelt
initiative as it's called which was
based on a secret telegram sent by
Washington in January 1938 offering the
prospects of an international conference
to discuss disarmament etc etcetera that
plan was first conceived by Sumner
Welles a member of the State Department
his boss executive State Cordell Hull
didn't agree with him they were in
dispute over this within Washington
circles for a while but in the end the
president sent this telegram asking
whether or not the British
take the lead in requiring a conference
to be held just at the point when and
asking for disarmament to the point when
the British are really actually now
really giving their rearmament and
Chamberlain believing quite rightly that
this was again just another gambit by
the United States more words nothing to
reinforce it Center a mild rebuff and it
wasn't much of one and certainly
Roosevelt didn't take offense and in the
end there's some Wells initiative as it
really was a filing in March 38 the
point is that afterwards Churchill and
in trying to make a use great play of it
trying to say this was in Churchill's
was the less blessed chance to to avoid
a war what was he talking about there
was no prospect of avoiding a war based
upon some American verbal commitment the
fact of the matter is in 1939 in
September 39 the secretary stating of a
war in in Washington had to admit that
the Americans need to have one available
division to actually fight in Europe
that was the state of the American
military establishment only 2% of
American gross national product was
devoted to rearmament in 1939 compared
to 23% the Britain a 28 percent or
thereabouts for Germany right we had one
other question which we've now had in
two versions going to war over Poland
what wasn't that a waste of time
shouldn't we shouldn't Poland have been
in it wasn't it an acceptable casualty
we should have let Hitler occupy Poland
professor Charlie I they're both very
good questions and indeed they both
illustrate why Chamberlain's policy was
right because by 1939 it had become
clear neat secret intelligence reports
anymore you certainly didn't need some
press attache strike to sex up dossiers
pretty dangerous line let's not do that
people aren't actually that stupid you
can't actually change public opinion in
three weeks whatever a boastful chap
says in his diary
what changed opinion was Hitler breaking
his word what changed opinion was
what happened to Czechoslovakia and what
looked like it was going to happen to
Poland as Glenn said there were only two
countries in World War two that went to
war voluntarily that was Britain and
France after they had exhausted all
other possibilities and precisely the
same factors which were much of the
1930s militated against involvement in
1939 convinced most people
Harry Paulette the leader of the
Communist Party and sir Oswald Mosley
apart that the moment had come and there
was no alternative and that is why when
the disaster happened in 1930 1940 and
Britain was almost alone and under
tremendous threat public opinion did not
crumble
Churchill was right each contradict him
on one of the few occasions when he's
being modest but he was right when he
said I gave the lion's roar and the
reason the rat lion was roaring in favor
of a war where it had not previously is
that Neville had gone to the farthest
and to the uttermost and we can see and
everybody could see 1939 there was no
alternative that was not clear in 1938
right professor Evans responds it was a
Chamberlain himself did not see that in
1939 he was still appeasing away when
Poland was being invaded that he was
overruled by the House of Commons and
died a broken man a few months later yet
there was no limit to the policy of
appeasement it was not something where
we're which was going to have an end for
him he thought Mussolini could intervene
now my point is that Poland was not the
actual subject of the declaration of war
the subject the reason for war was the
final realization in British political
elite that and militarily that Germany
was about conquering the whole of Europe
and I agree with Professor Charlie
that realization came in March 1929 when
Hitler invaded the known german-speaking
part of the Czechoslovakia but of course
all of this could have been prevented
in 1936 over the remilitarization of the
Rhineland would French could have been
prompted by the British to move in and
invade and stop the Germans it could
have been done in September 1938 when
the British were prepared for war but it
was not also of course therein one
shouldn't just poopoo intelligence
intelligence reports were coming in it
there's a sort of curious footnote the
older members of the audience may
remember Peter Ustinov who was a wit
raconteur and actor and his father clock
was actually intelligence agents and
Euston off remembers and when he was
young a group of people in great secrecy
coming up tramping upstairs the flats
who talked to his father it turned out
later these were people who would come
to tell British intelligence service
that the German generals were going to
overthrow Hitler in 1938 if it came to
war did Chamberlain take any notice of
it no of course he didn't because he was
blind to this kind of thing in his manic
pursuit of appeasement right I will take
three more questions and then we will be
slowly moving on to summing up speeches
so right I think I'm right in saying
that Churchill was appointed First Lord
of the Admiralty by umm Chamberlain um
is that correct yeah so does this not
rather give light to the fact that the
proposition that Chamberlain was not
ultimately opposed to Nancy ISM by
appointing Churchill who um you pull in
my point
the Luftwaffe is coming sir then there
was one sorry blue shirt there and and
then one will take one more from the top
and then we'll have summing up the one
right this man right here
and with the panel agree that every time
Chamberlain appeased Hitler Germany got
stronger so for instance when Germany
took over Austria they managed to take
over all their reserves I think it's
about then about 800 million pounds
which is very valuable to them and when
they took over Czechoslovakia they took
over their industries
so by appeasing Hitler each time he
actually made him stronger and when it
came to war he put us right behind the
game and now we had one over here during
the 1930s not now in hindsight but
during the 1930s one crisis after
another you could see that Hitler was
achieving territorial gains and
appeasement kept continuing and he kept
making more territorial gains he kept
making Hitler kept making Hitler kept
was making territorial gain okay one
find out what this is the final question
then we will have summing up speeches in
which the panelists can answer whichever
of these questions they they they choose
before Munich Hitler had written mine
camp - looking for leoben's Helmer in
the east he had imprisoned large numbers
of the Communist Party and killed many
more in Germany and he had taken
opposite sites as Stalin in the Spanish
Civil War did Stalin really make a trade
with Hitler because he thought he could
get more out of it or because he was
desperate at the lack of serious
cooperation from the British on the
French right thank you very much so for
final questions
what if he's meant the easiest policy
for British in the 1930s the best for
Hitler every time Hitler gained more -
every time Hitler was appies he gained
more pop more territory more power I
will let the panelists think about these
questions and as they print as they
prepare their summing up speeches and
while they do so and while they speak uh
sure's will be
around with ballot boxes for the final
vote and once again a reminder you vote
by tearing your ballot ticket which was
handed to you upon entry into and you
vote by placing either the for or
against part into the ballot box and if
you are don't know
then you should place the entire ticket
into the ballot box and vote for both
sides ok summing up speeches will be
made while you vote and they will each
last 2 or 3 minutes and we make them in
the reverse order to which they were
that speakers spoke at the beginning so
first goes Piers Brendan I'm fairly
unprepared to do this what what what I
feel is the most important thing really
is that the the origins of this business
of appeasement go back to 1935 what I
was very struck by the by looking at
1935 and discovering that popular
opinion was absolutely outraged by
Mussolini's occupation of Ethiopia not
least of course because he was using
poisonous gas and because the British
who had got completely foolproof
evidence of the fact that he was using
poisonous gas refused to condemn him on
that Hanan fact got up in the hospitals
and said that he couldn't impugn the
honour of of a great country but the
British public and I think again and
again it comes back to this in a
democracy what are the people think and
in 1935 what they thought was strange
because we ourselves had had a long
Imperial tradition but they thought that
Mussolini's behavior in Ethiopia was
absolutely disgraceful now there wasn't
an easy option which we did not take
namely of blocking the Suez Canal and I
think this would have arts this sort of
satisfied outraged public opinion in
Britain it would have isolated Germany
it would have sent a signal to Hitler
that these that we were not political
eunuchs that we could in fact stand up
for ourselves and it would
something that we haven't talked about
at all it would have served notice on
Japan because don't forget that what was
going on all the time from 1931 onwards
was was the the continued nibbling away
of China by Japan breaking out into a
major war in 1937 the first the Second
World War started in 1937 in the Far
East this I think had we made a stand
there had we made a stand
the following year over the over um the
occupation of the Rhineland which would
have been easy the Germans hadn't got
any proper bullets in their guns they
had dummy bullets and they were under
orders to retreat if that if any
opposition was shown it would have been
the easiest thing in the world to stop
Hitler early and in 1935 would have been
backed by public opinion so I I sort of
see the Justice of what Churchill said
in his book on Second World War
um when he called it an unnecessary war
I rest my case on that right Thank You
Glenn stone I like to emphasize the kind
of strategic problems faced by Britain
in the 1930s because we are not only to
consider Europe we had to consider the
Mediterranean we had to consider the Far
East as well and it would have been
massively helpful to the British if the
Americans have come in and helped us in
the Far East and certainly Chamberlain
hoped that the Americans would do that
but they fail to offer any real support
in the Far East as much as in Europe and
elsewhere this created really proms
Ferrari armament because we utter rearm
our naval air and land forces and that
would require enormous amounts of
investment that investment was made made
under considerable basis both through
increased taxation and through loans and
so on but in the end it would never be
sufficient to actually beat a Germany by
ourselves or even in tandem with the
French when I'm allowed to look at the
First World War to see that it had taken
for great power
is to finally bring Germany to the to
surrender in 1918 and indeed it took a
combination of powers during the Second
World War to achieve that as well and
there was no prospect of as being able
to do that or fighting a war certainly
to win a war more importantly probably
not to lose a war without the support of
other other great powers and the United
States was in a sense the real problem
if the Americans had been prepared to
give that kind of support then maybe it
would have been a different story but
it's interesting to note that in 1914
when we were actually now at war with
Germany along with the French during the
period called the phoney war Sumner
Welles came to Europe and visited Paris
and Berlin and London and he talked
about making concessions to to Germany
he actually angered Chamberlain because
he won't even consider the idea of the
dismissing Hitler he was prepared to
actually even think for a moment about
it Hitler continuing as as a leader of
Germany and as I said gem Lee was
incensed that was a kind of thinking
that was going on in the State
Department through the 30s and into the
Second World War there was still a
possibility of making a settlement and
of reaching some kind of agreement with
what with the Hitler even in March 1940
fact in the matter was what they didn't
want what they really feared and is what
they got was a Europe particularly
Eastern Europe that will be dominated by
the Communists and in the end that is
what happened that failure to give real
and concrete support to Britain in
France ended with their great nightmare
that in the end your it was divided and
it was divided between communism and
capitalism thank you thank you Richard
Evans just to come back to one or two of
the last questions did appeasement make
Germany stronger yes undoubtedly did
appeasement encourage Hitler yes I
argued that in my speech did Stalin just
do a deal with Hitler because he
despaired of the British and the French
being able to do a deal yes he was
desperate of course he will one thing we
all agree on I think is that Soviet
Union was weak after all the purges of
the armed forces Venetians factories and
so on at the end of the 1930s darling
terrified wanted some kind of temporary
stability while he put things back
together again I just want to come back
also to four stones arguments about
Britain's seeking alliances and so on
all of this would not have been
necessary had appeasement not destroyed
the credibility of the League of Nations
the League of Nations was what was a
collective security the idea the idea
that what happened
in 1935 with the invasion of Abyssinia
was that the League of Nations attempted
and made a valiant attempt to try and
condemn Mussolini to try and raise
sanctions all of this is very popular
United Kingdom but it was completely
sabotage by the British government
because it believed in one-to-one
diplomacy not in invoking collective
security in that destroyed any further
prospect of it so the final point I want
to make is about the economy the British
economy was far stronger than the German
it survived the depression much much
better than the than the German economy
journey is extremely hard hit by the
depression and it took a long time to
recover recovery was driven by real Mon
but it didn't really happen until the
very late nineteen nineteen thirties in
the mid 1930s Britain was a much
stronger economic position to to deal
with Germany had it wished to write
thank you John Charlie has the last word
for change um well I did enjoy the Alice
in Wonderland world with 20/20 hindsight
produces in which this war like Italy
was always determined on war was
determined on war because he was
appeased what you've been deter Owen if
some German generals were going to
shooting at German James was gonna shoot
Hitler and when they finally got rounds
trying to do it they mucked it up
God really let's give it a whole Empire
millions to war on the on the rumor that
some German generals gonna get your shot
right that's a good one
oh the wisdom of the Monday Morning
Quarterback
it's wonderful
the fact is the policy was as Paul
Schroeder and Paul Kennedy have said the
most over determined in British history
now weather was possible
Richard is of course quite right the
British economy was strong by 1939
that's because Neville had not
bankrupted the country by going for the
stupid rearmament Churchill wanted which
would have produced a bunch of
medium-range bombers in 1940 wouldn't a
pretty Churchill wasn't in favor of
Spitfires or radar he wanted
medium-range bombers that would have
worked now come mom I do hope you've
voted the right way but it was a
wonderful exercise in nostalgia
listening to the other side I feel like
Eric welcome they gave the same old
arguments but not necessarily in the
right order
thank you thank you thank you thank you
to all of our panelists
yeah I know well they don't have the
voucher as we are still waiting for the
vote I am I'm going to take away from
John charm lead the the last word and
I'm going to hand it to want to decide
because both of them were groaning and
making faces at the same time you were
groaning - but you got yourself one
final response whichever one of you
wants it here's Brendan and then we'll
have the vote after you know after you
know we're talking about this some kid
says I'll give it wait I say he'll give
it wit um I think I'm right out of wish
at the moment um half-wit perhaps no I
was this an exercise in nostalgia we
should you should maybe answer that
question I don't I think John's
position is is completely indefensible
on this and I I said at the last
consultation that we had with him that I
would I would um support any particular
argument that he was against and I
certainly I said makes it easy that on
this particular occasion we're justified
in doing this I beg of you do not allow
this this spurious argument that he has
been putting forward to convince you
that um that he's right to lay and now I
have the secret bedroom but also it was
also John John's final speech was also
far too late because you'd already voted
by then thank you yes I I should point
out that our some of our panelists voted
on the way in and some of them didn't so
there by there by twisting the initial
vote anyway we now have the result
before the debate there was 25% for the
motion and after the bait 44% for before
the debate there was 41% against the
motion after the debate 52% against the
motion
who don't know shrunk from 34% to 4% so
Bravo to all the panelists for having
changed at least 30% of my
you